what do you what do you think of the the
new rule to require vaccination of all
NHS staff
so I've had Cove at some point yeah I've
got antibodies yeah
um I've been working on Covert IQ since
the beginning I have not had a
vaccination
I did not want to have a vaccination
um
the vaccines reducing transmission only
for about eight weeks with Delta with
Omicron it's probably less
and for that I would be dismissed if I
don't have a vaccine it's not the
science isn't strong enough
yeah sure for you and and your views do
you have any view on that is that I
respect that but there's a there's also
many questions
but yeah
another colleague who's also in the same
position yeah
yeah no I understand that and obviously
we have to weigh all that up for both
Health and Social care and there will
always be a debate about it but maybe
there's an opportunity to reconsider
with Omicron and the changing picture or
at least the nuances and allow doctors
who've had antibody exposure
who've got antibodies yeah you haven't
had the vaccination
to not have it because the protection
I've got from transmission is probably
equivalent to someone who's vaccinated
yeah but at some point that will win as
well but if you want to provide
protection with the booster yeah you'd
have to inject everybody every month
if it's worn off by two months
yeah if it's what if the protection is
worn off a transmission after two months
yeah then after a month you've still got
a bit of protection yeah so you want to
maintain protection you're going to need
to boost all staff members every single
month which you're not going to do
you know we take advice on on when how
much you made but it's not going to
achieve a practical benefit yeah well we
take the very best advice that we can
understand from the people that are
vaccine experts